you think you can fix me gene you are  not broken  beautiful friend the mind is a fragile  thing takes only the slightest tap to  tip it in the wrong direction  Charles what did you do I had to keep a  stable I protected her from the truth  there's another word for that I came  looking for answers you feel like you  don't belong here  you don't they can't begin to comprehend  what you are she's changing  that's what you didn't come here looking  for answers you came here looking for  pollution  she's arranged  hey miss war coming out of us  gene lost control was she still our  friend this is your fault Charles the  world is on the brink I'm sorry I didn't  stop it sooner you're always sorry  Charles  and there's always a speech and nobody  cares they're still  don't do this  the right to fear me  I've seen evil  I'm looking at it now  you  [Music]  you